brest chez molière mère-courage entre au
répertoire et c'est catherine hiégel qui
porte une bonne partie de la pièce sur
ses épaules la critique est unanime du
grand et du beau théâtre dominique
poncet yvon bodin c'est la guerre
affrontant la mitraille une femme
traverse les champs de bataille avec ses
enfants et sa carriole qui lui sert de
boutiques ce qu'il ya d'exceptionnel
dans cette mère courage écrite par
bertolt brecht c'est qu'à elle seule
elle nous donne à voir tous les
comportements que [ __ ] dues à la
guerre les pires comme les meilleurs
sicile sud ursule jours c'est pour ça
que je crois qu'il faut pas être trop
âgés dans 20 ans je n'aurais pas pu
c'est lourd c'est c'est très fatigant
enfin les victoires et les défaites des
progrès en oz des gens d'en bas tel
point toujours pas beaucoup prennent la
même vk pour légende en bois
la défaite est en réalité hague
l'honneur est perdu meriadeg le
personnage sortira de cette aventure
sans avoir compris ce que la guerre à
d'horribles un personnage éclairer le
but c'est que peut-être chaque
spectateur se retrouve avec une
réflexion par rapport à la violence par
rapport à la guerre par rapport à la
monstruosité que des êtres peuvent
devenir
je crois que c'est ça qui est le plus
important c'est de faire ressentir sa
génitrice affligé je suis jamais ouvrir
lui fonctionnel et dans la fleur de
l'âge
s'ils veulent un soldat il faudra mordre
l'herbe c'est sûr d'être audacieux comme
son père j'ai pas mal
il fêtera sa peau moi je suis fiable
dans ce spectacle je suis toujours
heureuse à la fin d'une représentation
parce qu'elle a abouti puisque quelque
chose s'est fait quelque chose d'unique
ce qu'une orientation et c'est quelque
chose d'unique donc
fier d'avoir avec mes camarades
participer à ce moment donné aux autres
moments très forts puisque la pièce de
brecht sonne ici comme une dénonciation
qui pourrait avoir été leakée
aujourd'hui